thank you thank you justin
you've got a very anglo-american crowd
here so you know the whole phrase you
say tomato we say tomato
you say potato we say potato
you say cockburn we actually say coburn
um
it's just a chorus that was left out of
the song
we're here to celebrate an extraordinary
book and an extraordinary man and in
keeping with the spirit of alexander i
hope that the
crowd who were at the memorial last year
will forgive me if i begin the way that
i began then which is recalling what you
would hear every morning if alexander
stayed with you in your home
you would be
barely awake bleary at the crack of dawn
thinking of all the things that lay
before you tasks and trials and
tribulations for the day
and you would hear not from the bed in
the guest room because alexander didn't
really like sleeping in best guest room
beds he much preferred lying out on the
couch in the living room
you would hear rising from the living
room
a voice an unmistakable voice
saying
so
are you ready to greet the day with
unbridled optimism
and i think we should all just
meet him in that chorus right now are we
ready to greet the day with unbridled
optimism
[Music]
fair
enough i want to thank power house arena
verso books for putting out such a
gorgeous book um all those who helped in
the pulling together of this book we'll
hear more about the process in just a
minute
and also thanks c-span
who interviewed alexander in a wonderful
feature that i'm sure they will make
available for people who want to see it
and before i forget i'm sure that we
will be remembering throughout this
evening the extraordinary newsletter
that alexander co-founded now edited by
jeffrey st claire counterpunch and you
can find it at counterpunch.org
and i'm sure c-span will be kind enough
to run that in the lower third
underneath at least a few times in the
next hour
right this is a gathering of friends of
alexander any foes
damn it
he would have enjoyed that um
on the platfor platform here you have um
a niece of alexanders
a brother of alexanders and the daughter
of alexander
we lost him a year ago barely it seems
like
both way too long ago and no time at all
we all of us have different personal
stories as well as professional stories
to share i think this evening you're
going to hear a little bit of both
the book that you're talking about that
we're talking about is a colossal wreck
a road trip through political scandal
corruption and american culture you'll
hear a little bit about alexander's
fondness for road trips
his um
enduring quest not really to get through
political scandal and corruption but to
reveal it
and his real love affair with american
culture which comes through strongly in
the pages of this book a little
background just so you know the book is
coming out now you just heard that he
died a year ago he was working on this
book pretty much until the day that he
died
and it was pieced together
partly thanks to the process that he and
jeffrey had developed a counterpunch
where every year at the end of the year
they would publish a greatest hits
column of their pieces over the
preceding 12 months and this had enabled
alexander to keep a pretty good track on
his favorite parts of his own um his own
uh herv
as they say in england um and
the book was then
put together with extraordinary help
from from daisy from jeffrey from andrew
uh in between feeding his animals
responding to the crisis of the day
talking to percy his cockatiel on his
shoulder and talking to anybody else in
the community of petroleum where he
lived who might need his help or
assistance or advice
on repairing their vintage vehicle
alexander
pulled together
a colossal wreck as well as a wonderful
collection of articles about words that
should be forever banished
you can find all the information at
counterpunch.org
and i'll just say
that this book is pretty much as he
wanted it daisy can attest
um
i'm incredibly glad it's out here
it reminds us that alexander while he
hated cliches
uh he did very much live up to the one
about um comforting the afflicted and
afflicting the comfortable
you'll hear a lot about afflicting the
comfortable but
um i just want to share a little bit of
his comfort for the afflicted he he had
a
incredibly reliable ability to stand up
for the underdog uh and defend those who
were powerless in our media culture and
in our society and sum up the imbalance
of power very perfectly workers for
example on february 28
1996 he wrote the love of our newspapers
for free trade surely has something to
do with the fact that although there has
been fearsome attrition in the
journalistic profession at least the
loss of jobs here on at least the lost
jobs here aren't reappearing south of
the border at a fraction of the cost
the day the column writing is
subcontracted to high school students in
guatemala i expect to see a turnaround
on the trade issue among the opinion
forming classes
he stood up for young people may 22nd of
the same year
the hysteria about teen violence is more
than matched by the alarms about
pubescent rutting about a pubescent
rutting boom with children having
children
and children giving one another aids
bill and hillary seldom stop sermonizing
on this adults listen agog to the
boastful lies of teenage boys and then
rush to judgment in 1970 20 percent of
boys and four percent of girls in junior
high schools claimed on self-reporting
surveys to have had sex
in 1992 the figure had risen to 27
percent of boys and 20 percent of girls
and if rising legions of pubescence were
sexually active how come the pregnancy
rate among 10 to 14 year olds hasn't
simply similarly skyrocketed in 1976 3.2
babies abortions and miscarriages per
100 junior high school girls in 1988 3.3
amid this supposed junior high sexual
revolution 98 percent of girls arrived
at age 15 without ever having been
pregnant
junior high school students must be
america's most skilled condom deployers
seventh graders should be enlisted to
hold seminars for u.s grown-ups who
sport the industrial world's highest
rates of unplanned pregnancy
and finally standing up for animals and
a charming piece about the democratic
convention and how conventions in
general like to um republican and
democratic like to
set up in
tourist attraction towns he talked about
the republican convention in san diego
and somehow the story of the convention
merged with his story of sea world
which is part of the landscape there
sea world owned by the anheuser-busch
corporation and host to about four
million visitors a year same as the zoo
was a favorite venue for convention
events
nourished by the kitsch atmospherics of
purity and la mer with dolphins and orca
recruited with behavioral techniques to
exhibit the fundamental harmony of
creation under corporate auspices
sea world is non-union with minimum wage
levels for the attendance at least the
zoo is teamster organized
though through uh
though there should be more
inter-species union work why leave it
all to the human society
in the polar bear exhibit a big new pool
with enhanced underwater availability
three of the bears
had salmonella poisoning and were
confined to what the guide pri brightly
termed their bedrooms this meant
compulsory overtime for 18 month old
chinook who was putting in 13-hour days
i thought chinook looked afraid and
angry when i saw him but the guide
insisted the cub was doing a quote real
good job
in exhibiting polar bearishness to the
audience
chinook could do with a union rep same
way poor dunder the elephant needed one
a few years back when it was discovered
she was being savagely beaten for
disciplinary infractions don't snarl
organize
every now and again orangutans organize
an intifada
the last was in 1990 when the bournean
apes carefully built up reserves of
rocks and caused 570 thousand dollars
worth of damage to the one and a half
inch glass
alexander is going to be recalled here
by andrew coleman who is not only
alexander's youngest brother but
washington editor of harper's magazine
and the author most recently of rumsfeld
rise falling catastrophic legacy his
rise fallen catastrophic legacy also by
doug henwood who is the publisher of the
left business observer by conor
kilpatrick editor at jacobin magazine a
contributor
to many others besides
daisy coburn will follow up and we will
take just a few questions but if you
really want to get close to any of us
and ask us any really personal family
questions you have to have a purchased
book in hand
[Applause]
a master salesman you agree
i think uh
i think alexander would be very happy
right now not just at this
happy crowd come here to
review his career and maybe even by his
book um
was it
grounds for excitement but also at
this glorious past two weeks when the
war party's been utterly confounded the
uh
uh the punditry who i mean in mass ranks
marching in lockstep to lead us into
leaders into syria have been thrown back
by the collective shout of derision from
the people i can sort of sort of i
couldn't quite couldn't put it as well
as he would have but i can certainly
hear his
tones of exaltation at this
uh very revolutionary events for the
last couple of weeks plus the
humiliation of
the idiot john kerry and perhaps uh
there would have been a very
sapient commentary on the uh
uh our prose style of that newborn
pundit vladimir putin um
really serves as an example to us all
but um i think you know when alexander i
hope you uh those who don't know him
already will come to know him a lot
better when you read the book and you
will realize what a tremendous influence
on alexander
uh our father was claude who um
was himself a radical journalist and in
a way i'm going to read a little bit
about what alexander said about claude
which in a way particularly in talking
about his writing style
very much
is
refers to alexander too
he wrote fast with a beautifully easy
style his prose could be light ironic
also savage
he was learned but never overbearing
cultivated but never patronizing he
respected and enjoyed people at all
social levels and ages
he loved dogs
under the force of his example who could
resist the lure of journalism none of
his sons did to the initial gloom of our
mother patricia who knew firsthand that
freelance journalism doesn't always
bring home regular slabs of bay bacon i
write she was
his body simply wore out when he was 77
though his mind stayed sharp until his
last breath
the day before he died at centenbar's
hospital in cork he dictated a column
for the irish times to patricia
he never sounded on his ideals never
lost faith in humanity's noble
noble instincts never failed to see the
humor in life
and uh um i think if you're thinking
about alexander those words apply just
as well to him including the
uh terminal uh
the
dictation of a column is a very last
column to in this case alexander's
daughter daisy in his uh very
within days almost hours of the end of
his life
alexander i should say
although he wrote sapiently and
pungently about politics and about
everything the human condition
he had
uh
a very well developed sense of theater
which he applied in that's why his
political writing was so
uh entertaining because he applied he
brought he considered politics as a form
of theater among other things um
so in reflecting the
multiple disappointments of the obama
presidency or
they may strike some at least some of us
i thought i'd just read something from
november 24 2009
are his thoughts about obama
or one aspect of obama
no one told us it would be boring but it
is the obama presidency
having an adulterer and a [ __ ] at 1600
pennsylvania avenue for eight years
apiece plus dick cheney down the
corridor spoiled us what side of bill's
head did hillary hit with the lamp
would george bush would george fight his
way to the end of his sentence of a
sentence in these daily battles with the
english language
these days tranquility reigns all seems
to in the obama's private quarters
senior white house staffers remain loyal
and tight-lipped small wonder jay leno's
nightly show is sagging there was
nothing to make jokes about at least
until sarah palin went on her book to
her
politics is getting duller by the day
too as the idealists watched their
expectations trickling all too swiftly
through the hourglass what's left
enforcing private coverage and savaging
the medicare advantage plans of
low-income seniors obama has dipped
below 50 percent in public approval
which so the pollsters tell us is
nothing particularly unusual for new
president president at this stage of the
game what's going to stop him sliding
sliding down more
and so and as you know obama came back
but nothing much improved really
um life didn't get any more entertaining
michelle never threw a lamp so far as we
know it obama
um obama whatever else he can't do does
construct his sentences nicely
so um
alexander would have been disappointed
that but he would have been i can
imagine the
exaltatory call i would have gotten in
recent weeks from him
um which thankfully since i lived three
hours later he lived on the west coast i
live on the east so
he would have had no qualms about waking
me up in the morning but so happens i
was the one who could wake him
um but
given the turn of a recent turn of
events in syria
uh he would have been pleased to have
written this on
february 17th last year
few spectacles have been more surreal
than that of senior u.s officials
starting with the president the
secretary of state and the u.s
ambassador to the u.n
solemnly lecturing assad and his
beleaguered syrian government on the
need to accommodate rebel forces
whose uh arabian gulf sponsors are
intent on slaughtering the ruling
alawites minority or driving them into
the sea
at one grimly hilarious moment last
friday these worthy sermons were
buttressed by a message from ayman
al-zawahiri the head of al-qaeda
therefore presumably the number one
target on president obama's hit list
similarly praising the lions of syria
for rising up against the assad regime
al-qaeda and the white house in sync
so
so in some of ways things he would
recognize the world he left a year ago
um
but he would be sad i know he'd be sad
to miss it to be missing at all the
endless
joy in theater and particularly
america i mean i say in my introduction
to the book some fool in england some
ghastly blairite uh one said it just
attacked alexander as anti-american
um because he would he would in turn has
been properly derisive about
the excesses of the clinton era um
the political excesses not the sexual
excesses which you certainly didn't care
about um
and i thought what an idiot alexander
loved this country he knew it better
than
99 of americans he traveled endlessly
uh back and forth he
uh
he in fact he traveled so much and wore
out so many cars that among the more
touching memorials or letters of
condolence we got uh that arrived after
his death was one from his insurance
agents signed by a
long list of people saying that they'd
really enjoyed dealing with him and he
was going to be a sad loss
and that's only one of the many groups
you wouldn't think of who mourn my
brother as i do every day thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
alex coburn is probably more than half
the reason i uh got into the prestigious
and high-paying field of radical
punditry
so uh i
have a great deal of gratitude uh for to
him for for all these many decades of
of pursuing this um strange career
um i was fresh out of college in 1975 i
had a job at a
small little brokerage firm on wall
street that eventually went bust and one
of my fellow drones uh working there
said you should check out this guy
alexander yes cockburn in the village
voice
and i said okay i will yeah yeah and i
did and i was immediately hooked
uh it was the first place i learned
reading his press clips column there
that the new york times didn't always
tell the truth um you know i had an
understanding a vague understanding of
politics but alex really reading his
columns really helped me fill them in
fill in the details
and then i went off to the university of
virginia after the brokerage firm went
under and uh carried the village voice
with me into uh the hinterlands of
charlottesville
uh and it was really
quite a marvelous paper the boys in the
late 70s or early 80s and but alex from
my point of view was was the star of it
i love the style of those old press clip
columns press clips columns they're the
rude and loose
uh sort of uh
journalistic uh diaristic style of those
almost and there's some of that feel in
in a colossal wreck i was just
observations about this and that uh
books uh
uh food uh lies on the tv uh just
meandering from one
uh profound or witty observation to
another um
uh then i followed him of course when he
went to the nation uh and uh you know i
think the the style of the column
changed somewhat uh whenever one writes
for the nation one tends to straighten
one's posture and uh sober up somewhat
and i know alex fought heroically
against those uh tendencies and was an
inspiration to all of us who write for
the nation but uh it's sometimes an
uphill battle uh
but the late 80s mid and late 80s were
grand days of the nation uh not only
alex was doing great work there but uh
also his uh sometime friend and
collaborator uh
andy copkind uh was doing some great
stuff there signed and unsigned and a
voice
very much
missed by some of us nation readers
today
uh anyway uh it was uh reading alex in
the voice in the nation that inspired me
to think about uh
writing about economics and finance
political economy i think the uh i
thought at that time that the the left
writing on that was either uh rather uh
dull or out of date or not uh in tune
with the headlines i thought
maybe i could do something like this one
day reading the newsletter rock and roll
confidential which was an eight-page
newsletter by edited by dave marsh uh i
thought hmm maybe i could do one of
these myself so i just started doing my
own newsletter left business observer uh
and um
and it actually
sort of took off by the low standards of
the radical journalism trade
um so i would launch myself onto a
little career as a as a pundit on the
dismal science
um i can't say i knew alex well
personally we would talk from time to
time on the phone actually
his last two-page column in the magazine
just before they cut it back to one page
and of course they would later cut him
back to once a month
about two-thirds of that last two-page
column came from a phone conversation we
were having i would say thanks to him
and it was like a master class in
writing i would say something and then
he would type it uh and in in his own
language and it was just amazing to hear
my my what i was saying translated uh
transformed into something really
radiant and
i was really
i felt like i was sitting at the feet of
a master while watching him work it was
really a marvelous experience
um
the um we did have our differences and
there were a few years where we actually
didn't speak much uh there was a moment
in the verso office i recall where i
think the word sexist pig passed from my
lips
uh well the my memory of that is a
little murky uh and um you know i got a
little annoyed about some of the stuff
about climate change and then we
uh had some disagreements about the
militias and uh although i went part of
the way with him on that but not all the
way
um but i i decided uh to renounce
feuding and
several years ago we made up and
started talking again and
i did an interview with him about a year
before he died with for my radio show
we did it by skype and uh
the video image on the screen was of
him with his uh cockatiel pershi sitting
on his shoulder i assume percy was named
after uh the author of the the words
colossal wreck
uh and it was it was a marvelous
interview it was started by talking
about it was right after jack schaefer i
think had been fired by slate so we
decided to talk a little bit at the
beginning about press criticism
and since alex was uh you know the
creator of a modern school of press
criticism in in this country
we talked some about that he thought you
know he had just gotten kind of old and
tired everybody now was a media critic
and it uh had gotten uh it got a little
old and it was nice to see that he'd
moved on from that
um
and as i said we had our
certainly had political differences um
but good god what a marvelous writer and
thinker he was until the very last
minute
and uh i want uh to read just a little
something he wrote in november 2011 uh
in the nation i remember when this came
out it arrived in the mailbox and i was
i i was so excited by these paragraphs
these two paragraphs that i read them
about five times then read them aloud to
my wife liza featherstone fellow nation
writer
uh and uh here it goes it was right
after in the midst of the occupy moment
i have to admit writing these lines at
the start of november that after
digesting the daily reports on our
national battlefield zuccotti park oscar
grand plaza austin philadelphia atlanta
nashville portland
my eyes flicker across the world map to
greece and my heart beats a lot faster
now they're there surely we can see the
whiff of a pre-revolutionary situation
it must be the droughted leninist in me
even after all these years of therapy
surfeited with somewhat turgid pins to
the democratic gentility of the owsers i
clamber to the top dusty top top shelf
furtively hauled down vladimir's uh uh
april theses of 1917 and dip in
and uh
uh and dip in end the war confiscate the
big estates immediately merge all the
banks into one gen giant national bank
the blood flows back into my cheeks my
eyes sparkle then hearing my daughter's
furtive steps outside the library i
shove lennon back into place scuttle
back down the ladder and pluck a copy of
eva ef schumacher even though i'm not at
all sure
what is on the os ow esther's reading
lists or twitter menus
um the leninist in him which is
something that still appeals to me
there's still a lot of that myself
in our in that last interview i did with
him for my radio show in uh the summer
of 2011
with percy perched on his shoulder
alex identified a problem that people
don't really spend their youth in
marxist parties anymore reading the
classics
and because of that a rigor and
understanding that you just can't find
on instagram is lost
um but we do have this capacious new
volume to savor and also uh to quote a
line from london that alex like to quote
uh we can be as radical as reality
itself uh that kind of
thinking might not get you on msnbc but
who wants the approval of a
semi-official arm of the bourgeois state
anyway
[Applause]
thank you i had a feeling we both picked
the linen bit so i just i just knew it
uh hello my name is connor kilpatrick
i'm an editor at jackman magazine a new
print quarterly of the socialist left
that i help edit along with my comrades
peter freys on the audience megan
erickson and bosker sunkara who is
lurking around here somewhere i believe
uh i'm completely honored to have been
invited to speak here but uh seeing as
how everyone else here is either a
relative of alex's or a personal friend
i'd like to talk about what his writing
meant to someone who never met or
corresponded with him uh
someone as a who has a dreaded
millennial such as myself arrived on the
socialist left during the bush obama
years thanks in large part to the
brilliant polemics of alexander coburn
so
i'm guessing everyone here knows alex's
great bit about his hate being pure
is that
is that is that correct well if you
don't know the story it's a tradition
that alex inherited from his editor jim
goode who'd test alexander's morale and
commitment to the good fight by asking
him if his hate for the powerful was
truly pure alex would then put the same
question to his interns at the nation
one such intern a young ed miliband soon
to be the next prime minister of the uk
replied with with shock that no he
didn't hate anyone and as alex put it
it's all you really need to know and my
god it really is
uh so yes alex alex's hatred was most
certainly pure but somehow for me that
doesn't really get at what made his
writing so wonderful because it was a
joyful hate that alex nurtured an
inspiring hate
for all this the talk of his sharp
tongue and even sharper pen we are after
all talking about a man who once
confessed to weeping on an airplane as
he watched 1993's homeward bound the
incredible journey a film about two
talking dogs and a sassy cat trying to
make their way back home and i believe
he was sitting next to a woman in ad
sales who was a little bit freaked out
by that
uh
so once a lot of the my discovery of
alex's work uh came you know as a
millennial it wasn't just his writing it
was also uh through youtube uh watching
video clips of alex on c-span recordings
from the 1980s or as i get to later a
anti-war rally in eureka california
so uh one time i came across a video of
a mid-1980s c-span appearance of alex's
the callers that day were
hostile accusing him of being a foreign
communist of sorts
but alex kept up his spirit smiling all
the way through without being any
without any kind of snottishness or
anything
one particularly angry young man i
remember called in and shouted
don't smile at me and alex replied that
he could smile all he wanted to and then
he let him have it
a tight grin those marvelous coburn
family cheekbones aimed right at the
camera and i just it really left an
impression on me
uh as great as alex's pros is the man
could really he could just as easily
deliver a fiery sermon which is truly a
lost art on the left i'm sad to say
not only the dozens of appearances over
the years on those shows such as the
c-span but more obscure bits like a
grainy video of alex speaking at an
anti-war rally in rainy eureka
california just outside the humboldt
county courthouse it's on youtube have a
look in this one alex is standing next
to an actual guillotine just to his
right he starts off with a few facts
about the guillotine it was invented by
a liberal
he then goes on to deliver a passionate
defense of both the french revolution
and popular sovereignty and the
guillotine itself and i quote
if every corporate chieftain in the
united states as he told his employees
to break the law as he asked his lawyers
to get him off the hook as he cheated
people with his products if he knew that
there was one possibility that the blade
would go up and the blade would come
down we'd have a better society
i remember one of my favorite cobra
spiels was from tao raspooli's
documentary behind the wheel in the
first clip right at the peak of the bush
administration's power
alex says sure everything's gone to hell
and of course there's no hope but alex
said bread and coffee
bread and coffee today in the united
states are infinitely better than what
it was when he first came here the
staples of life he says and he wasn't
joking around he was serious
this was the kind of thing no one cares
about but he was right there was change
we could believe in one third of lenin's
peace land bred and that's nothing to
scoff at
and then he went on you do what you can
you have to take the long view sometimes
supposing we're in the roman empire in
300 a.d we're radicals inside the roman
empire we've seen there's a future for
secular leftism in the roman empire
actually if you took the long view
people would say these people were
completely insane in the 3rd century
because there's centuries of not exactly
radical advance ahead of them but they
but were they wrong to say i think we
can nationalize land release all the
slaves build a communal society in
northern tuscany and that always struck
me as the coburn version of kafka's
famous dictum there is hope but not for
us which personally has always struck me
as wonderfully inspiring
so alex's hate ever pure is just the
twin of and i'm sorry to sound like a
total hippie here his love his love of
america's lost interior his love of
freaks and weirdos and the losers and
the forgotten what's remarkable about
all of this is that alexander stayed a
radical for his entire life even as the
last several decades were spent watching
the liberal left transformed into
something beyond stupidity i don't know
how he did it i certainly couldn't have
managed i'd have been running for either
an mba program or an organ commune
as i was telling some friends of mine
jackman i just can't imagine what it
must feel like to come to the us as a
committed left radical the son of claude
coburn in the early 1970s and have to
watch the whole sorry affair of carter
clinton and obama play out for decades
but thank god he was here because in the
words of cormac mccarthy he carried the
fire and when he passed it off i
couldn't honestly care less if he'd
taken a few detours from the correct and
proper socialist path because that was
half the joy of reading his work
as a fairly predictable socialist in my
generation i'm sure you can guess where
i differed with alex but the thing was i
stopped caring whenever i disagreed or
thought he was cozying up to the wrong
crowd or when i thought he was training
his fire on the wrong segments of the
left
not only because we needed to hear a lot
of it but because it was always tempered
with that optimism of his that joy
i spent the first 25 years of my life
feeling trapped in texas i was born to
conservative parents and raised in petty
bourgeois sun belt suburbs i grew up
around lots of fundamentalists lots of
republicans lots of football lots of
churches plenty of guns and of course
lots of deer and dove hunting
expeditions with my father's drunken
cajun buddies
at the 11 at the age of 11 in a
defiantly colorful keith herring printed
shirt i accepted an award from the texas
young rifleman's association for a
12-point buckeye shot i hated it all
like most left thinking kids growing up
in such places i got the hell out of
there as fast as i could and the truth
was that despite my supposed socialism
it made me a snob
alex however despite a healthy love for
folks like marx engels and the even
dreaded linen never became a snob
he never turned his nose up like i did
at the red states whenever i'd read him
talking about his encounters bumping
along the ex-confederate hinterland i'd
find myself saying god damn it alex
don't you get it these people are racist
theocratic quasi-fascist bastards if you
were from ireland you'd totally get this
when liberals and lefties dismissed the
tea party calling it an inauthentic
quote astroturf operation alex was quick
to call them on their smugness
quoting a website i believe called the
world socials website
and alex replied you think the
socialists left across america can boast
647 groups or of any single group
consisting of more than a handful of
people and he was right
alex was right to relentlessly pound
clinton liberalism and to show no mercy
to its defenders he was right to rebuke
them for embracing what he called fake
politics and he was right to call out
the left for having fled the battle
altogether and surrendered so much
energy passion and enthusiasm to the
right wing
and when a new radical left finally did
begin to slowly emerge he was also
correct
particularly about occupy wall street
which he approached with just the right
balance of enthusiasm and criticism and
while other lefties age were sounding
the trumpets for the return of a big
bold movement of reds
alex was far more cautious and he was
right to be
and uh i was going to read that bit
about taking linen off the shelf which
doug read so beautifully
uh and uh i thought that really
went to the core of him and kind of made
me when i first read that
the disagreements i had had with him and
they just
vanished immediately
alex knew that a smart organized and
politically minded left doesn't just
spring out of decades of
depoliticization he knew that pats on
the back wouldn't do them any good he
decried the collapse of a marxian left
which in his words
used to provide a training ground for
young people who could learn the
rudiments of political economy and
organizational discipline find suitable
mates and play their role in reproducing
the left red diaper upon red diaper
tomorrow's radicals nourished on the
marxist classics an adolescent soul not
inoculated by sectarian debate not
enriched by the 18th brew mayor and
study groups of capital is open to any
infection
and in this sense that al is in this
sense that alex played what i think was
his most valuable role for the left and
he might have perhaps hated this term
being an arden anti-militarist
but he was like our drill sergeant he
hurled abuse at us but beautifully
stated and almost always hilarious abuse
from every possible direction oh maybe
if hillary slap or maybe if i buy
organic slap oh if only the democrats
slap the kennedys were the last true
slap but why he was doing it why was he
doing it because he was mean
no because he wanted us to survive he
wanted us to win and honestly we needed
it thanks
oh hi everyone thank you so much for
coming along to celebrate
the launch of this um fantastic book
um
which really is a a treat and just um
filled with
such extraordinary and unusual stories
and
um
you know the uh my father's voice is
really really alive on
every page of this book and i found it
almost impossible to choose an extract
because i would flip through and oh this
one oh no it has to be this one
so i really hope you
you um find yourself with a copy
and uh and enjoy it
i'm just
going to read the first entry
um
which is actually an extract from a
letter he wrote to me in 1995
and his
letters his everyday speech his writing
all came from the same place and
um
uh
i'm lucky enough to have a a
collection of just incredible letters
from him and
postcards that he wrote
when i was a child
this one
he wrote oh yeah i said that already
sorry you wrote 95.
last year a mexican muralist with
nothing to do is here so i got him to do
an 18 foot by 8 foot ceiling mural on
the roof of my garage become library
roof meaning ceiling
i said it should more or less address
the theme of the meaning of the universe
so there were horses on the vault of
heaven and then being mexican he had a
peasant crucified to a corn cob and
lower down a great big skull and lower
down adam and eve looking really bummed
out
then some nice birds and an owl with the
wings extended
after a year of looking at this i bumped
into daniel the painter back from mexico
and said that i was anglo-irish not
mexican and so i wanted everything a bit
more bushy-tailed
the peasant not crucified but waving a
machete
no skull and adam and eve looking
excited as though they were off on a
lovely picnic
he digested all this with relatively
good grace and his american wife wagged
her head in strong agreement
i felt like pope julius telling
michelangelo to give up this idea of god
handing adam a formal note contract and
just have the hands reaching out know
what i mean mike
then what about instead of the skull the
spirit of the eternal
feminine daniel immediately wanted a
mayan type woman crouching in eternal
toil and suffering so i said no and dug
up a painting by dante gabriel rossetti
prosperia one of those pre-raph girls or
eyes and ray's shoulder and haunted me
and said try this one for the pose
then he needed a face so i think you are
going to end up on the ceiling of the
library holding a humboldt lily which
he's made the size of a gladiolus
the lily will have to be curbed and the
eternal feminine is a bit at odds with
everything else so we'll have to see i
hope you survived the final cut as they
say in hollywood
so i did survive the final cut and
there is my face looking very strange
amidst corn cobs and machetes and stuff
like that um
so that's uh maybe gives a sense of
what he was up to apart from
uh writing which was also creating an
extraordinary
um kind of paradise
filled with art that he'd commissioned
from local artists and
um
so he was up to a lot of
other stuff and then uh i'm just going
to read a short
extract from the afterward
um
when i was a teenager my father used to
suggest i read the dictionary when i had
a spare minute
or if i was feeling a bit down his own
father claude had recommended a dip into
marx if darkness descended
the point being made was a reminder not
to collapse to find meaning counter
chaos with spirited punches
get to the root of things and then
improvise blow your trumpet from there
and that's what he did and i think
that's what we're all
um what i'm hearing and what everybody's
saying is a a sense of his uh of his
voice which was like a trumpet
and
it's
just so exciting to have this book out
um
and i have nothing to say except please
buy it please enjoy it and thank you so
much for coming
i think we have time
i think we have time for a quick q a
for maybe two questions or so so let me
know if you have a question i can hand
the mic over to you
[Music]
if you guys have any concluding remarks
did everyone here just agree with
everything he wrote i can't believe that
he would have been very
[Music]
disappointed i i did not is this my
question
i i did not agree with everything he
wrote specifically about climate change
and
i think he was you know more sympathetic
to the militias
that than he should have been but he was
wonderfully acerbic
especially you know i think there's a
tendency among people to say like things
like oh like do you think hillary
clinton would be better than obama
and you know that would have gotten a
large dose of hydrochloric from alex's
pen
well this is entirely true
he would by the way have been
you'd probably have seen a line or two
in this column this week pointing out
that uh
i think antarctic ice has reached its
thickest extent uh since records began i
just noted that and thought of him and
thought he might be smiling the smug
smile um but yes he um
i mean he believed i mean he
i mean he was i mean
i wouldn't say he never met a man he
didn't like but he
there was no feature of american life
that he didn't embrace and explore and
you know take delight in um and i think
including i mean
on the mo at his funeral one of the more
moving speeches came from um
gentleman called dave ella who lives in
just outside spartanburg south carolina
who alexander bought his cars from and
as uh
daisy's now the prime proprietrix of a
very long line of
uh fairly aged vehicles uh down the side
of the road outside his house
all of which alexander
purchased from dave whose day job is to
be an evangelical preacher who has gone
around the world has even preached the
gospel in lasa tibet which i must say uh
something i wouldn't do but he um
and dave and alexander had a very close
bond um
many long conversations um
every week about
chrysler and about what was going on in
the evangelical community
um
i think very few sort of leftists
explored the features of american life
the way alexander did and uh i knew them
so uh
and we were you know everyone was the
richer for that
i mean alexander had a
on
he always i think always looked at the
impact of policy from the bottom up he
always looked at who would be on the
receiving end of the huge heavy hatchet
of government of regulation of war of
conflict
and that was i think what brought both a
passion to his work and sometimes also a
difference of opinion between those in
the pundit world even on the
journalistic pundit world who lived in
the land of the comfortable and had very
little sense of how some of the policies
they talked about would play out in the
land
one of the things you get from this book
that maybe we haven't shared enough is
a picture of how alexander actually
lived which i was lucky enough to see on
occasion and even in his last year when
i went out to spend time with him in
petrolia which is northern california
named after the first offshore drilling
that happened
off the coast there in the pacific
his community that daisy now knows so
well
was a community that was
in many ways outside of
u.s society a lot of barter a lot of
community building a lot of sharing a
lot of exchange a lot of people just
figuring out how to get along with each
other because they're living by the same
river and the same spirit of land 45
minutes from any local town
and
two hours if you want to redefine town
you're absolutely right
through twisting twisting
turning um redwoods and i just have to
i'm constantly struck by a moment that
happened soon after uh he died
a christmas party actually that we all
gave you daisy elizabeth
petrolia
to which many of the master craftsmen
that live in the valley
came to
remember alexander and as they went
around his house
talking about the things they had built
and the advice alexander had given
you got a glimpse of a life that they he
had given them
of care for beauty care for attention
care for their craft
that i just urge you to pick up the book
to read about because it's a part of his
life that i think was very special and
entirely informed so much else that we
hear about although he didn't
it wasn't on show to to everybody but i
don't know the daisy you want to to add
anything to that but i remember being
almost embarrassed listening to these
craftsmen
talk about their love for the work they
had done with alexander and their
mourning
for the man that was sort of their
medici the man who gave them the bait
the best
challenges we ever had they ever had and
i think to honor to to echo connor he
gave us the best challenges we ever had
too so for that i thank him
yeah i would just add something i mean i
think
he did give them challenges like
recreating a 14th century irish font in
the middle of the garden and it's not
something you'd normally be asked to do
as a as a carpent
well a stone maze in it well in this
case this is greg smith who can do
anything
um
so there really were you know very
interesting projects that they
collaborated on but also um i've been
really struck by people um saying how
they just can't recognize
the alexander coburn that they look up
on the internet um as the
kind of you know
generous friend that they
that they knew um in person so
there are a lot of people have just sort
of said um
you know have mentioned uh
oh what a great guy he was and how what
a nice man he was and
you know um
and not just as words of condolence but
really a sense of somebody who listened
very deeply
to people and um
and was a very thoughtful friend um
so
there is you know this other
um many other sides to him that um
you won't find if you look up
um
you'll you know you'll find acerbic and
um contrarian and those sorts of words
on the internet and they just bear no
relation at all to to who he was and
um and how people experienced him you
know cynical not for a second you know
acerbic never
contrarian what does that mean
so i mean obviously all those words are
just kind of last minute words that
people pull out when they don't know
what to say about someone
and they don't know very much about
somebody
so
yeah this book really contains a lot of
who he really was and i'll stop rambling
thank you all right so buy books come
meet us at the table we'll answer any
more questions you have and we'll share
other bits of information i believe the
book table is in the back here somewhere
yep register
register is at the front or where you
can purchase copies of the book and
let's hear one more time for our
contributors this evening
[Music]
and if you have
if you have any questions or if you
would like any of the contributors to
sign a copy of a colossal wreck they'll
be over at the signing table against the
wall over here so thank you so much for
coming out to powerhouse this evening
you're watching book tv non-fiction
authors and books every weekend on
c-span 2.